we all have weird food combos that we
learned when we were kids or that we
just love to eat
especially when we're alone don't
pretend like you don't get in that
fridge
and do some weird stuff all right my mom
actually
used to sit and dip a banana into sour
cream and bacon bits and i was like that
is disgusting and she said
try it and if you don't like it and i
did and it was amazing so
our next guest he loves weird food
combos too
and his social media is full of
delicious content
by the way he has more than a million
followers on tick tock
and did i mention he's 18. my daughter
and i love him welcome
eton
are you good morning i'm bernath excited
to be here oh eitan my daughter olive
and i
are so excited that you're on the show
and we love watching your videos i love
how you move around the camera i'm like
really into physical comedy so
your videos are so alive and i love your
reaction so i thought let's try some
unique food combinations together
yeah let's do it all right what's our
first combo
all right our first combo is cola and
peanuts now there's a little history
behind this one
where actually in the 20s uh workers
didn't want to have to hold their snacks
while they were working
so they actually put the peanuts inside
of the bottle of cola
so that they could drink and eat snack
at the same time and now it kind of
sounds like a choking hazard to me but
let's give it a try probably for kids it
is
definitely yeah all right let's give it
a try
okay that's just pretty good
you just changed my life i mean like
this isn't this
it's like it's kind of a vibe i like it
next
next up okay so the next one now one
thing i know you like bananas
from your weird food combo but i
absolutely despise bananas so i'm not
that excited for this one to be honest
we are doing i i don't i'm the problem
not bananas i know bananas are good i'm
the issue no you know what eitan like i
can't
stand goat's cheese and truffle and lamb
and that's like in
every food show i'm obsessed with food
shows everyone you mentioned like we all
watch
and i love cookbooks and that's how i
learn and
like i don't like these luxury
ingredients so we all have our thing
yes so we are doing a mayo and banana
sandwich now this one has a little bit
of fun facts to it the first fun fact is
that nascar driver dale earnhardt jr
actually
broke the internet by posting a picture
of a banana mayo sandwich
yeah totally broke the internet and
another fun fact is that the nationals
bullpen coach
actually credited their winning streak
to the banana mayo sandwich
that he ate before every game and the
last fun fact which is almost as crazy
is there is a facebook group
dedicated to mayo and banana sandwiches
not about you but i
am not a member of that group all right
i'm going in
all right let's give it a try
oh my god this would be jimmy fallon's
like worst nightmare he hates
mayonnaise so much yeah no i
i don't see myself joining that facebook
group anytime soon
i got to tell you i love it wait i don't
want to run out of time for our very
last one because i'm the most intrigued
by this
on go cinnamon with chili all right so
yes cinnabon to chili so this actually
originates from the midwest there's two
kind of stories one
is that kids at lunch in the midwest
would get chili and cinnabons for
dessert and they would dip the cinnabons
into the chili and another story is that
it was actually called the lagers
breakfast because the
people who worked in the walking
industry would take their leftover chili
pour it on their cinnabons for cinnamon
rolls for breakfast
and it would be like very high in
calories it sounds not that good to me
although
cinnamon sometimes is an ingredient in
chili so it might work
all right i'm going in all right
oh god no
oh god when i'm into it what's wrong
with
me i don't like it
so if anybody wants to tweet us
in about your weird food combinations
come play with eitan and i
use the hashtag drew's food combos and
then eitan you and i can like
look at some of them and see if we're
inspired by anything sounds good that
sounds like a lot of fun thank you so
much for having me oh heyton please come
back soon you're the greatest
you